from above the view appears to show a
city unaffected by yemen's civil war
but aidan's coastline tells a different
story
one of fishermen struggling to make ends
meet
mohammed yahya is one of them he
remembers when thousands of fishing
boats ventured onto the red sea coming
back with tuna sardines and lobster
now there are fewer fishermen and fewer
prospects
the price of boats and fishing materials
have gone up
the fighting and insecurity is really
affecting us economically
life in general is more difficult
before the war started seafood was among
yemen's top exports
but with years of fighting its ports and
processing sites have been destroyed
fishermen have been killed and thousands
more displaced
our days are unpredictable it all
depends on supply and demand sometimes
we buy a good catch from the local
fishermen and we make a profit other
days we lose money
[Applause]
most of yemen's 30 million people need
some form of humanitarian aid
buying fish has become a luxury many
can't afford
prices have doubled in some areas so
more fishermen are sending their catch
abroad for higher profits
about 500 000 people worked in the
fishing industry before the war
now it employs less than half
with limited fuel many can't afford
higher petrol prices for their boats and
others can't get out of debt
reports of fishermen who are killed at
sea aren't made public very often but we
know some of them got shot because they
got into restricted waters zones where
fishing is off limits because of the
conflict
but fishermen say the industry though
damaged is still a vital part of the
community and their livelihoods
they hope in time things will improve
for them
and their country
[Applause]
kazia lopez obayan al jazeera